in Hong Kong's lychicoke neighborhood
Hong navigates the challenges of being a
small business owner in a city that he
says feels unfamiliar after spending
almost two years in jail for his role in
the 2019 protests when I got arrested I
already had one child and my wife was
about to give birth to her second baby
my arrest had gained public attention
because I was a firefighter a civil
servant
their warehouse is just minutes away
from the prison he was jailed for
illegal assembly and carrying a petrol
bomb with a criminal record he can't
return to his old job
in 2019 Mass demonstrations swept
through Hong Kong in protest against a
proposed bill which would have allowed
extraditions to the mainland many
including Hong sword as a sign of
beijing's growing control over the
region when I took part in the protest I
knew that there was a risk of losing my
job but that was my least concern as I
could find another job
in prison he met fellow demonstrators
Cloris and Bernard now the three import
and sell fruit and are trying to rebuild
their lives I think a pessimistic
atmosphere is overshadowing Hong Kong
now everyone is scared under this new
Hong Kong acts of defiance are now far
more discreet while the mass protests
are over small signs of descent remain
tucked away in Alleyways and hidden
corners of the city
in 2020 Beijing introduced a new
National Security Law for Hong Kong
while many said it marked a serious
erosion in the city's Democratic
freedoms others said drastic action was
needed to return stability to the city I
don't believe in violence I don't
believe in you know demonstration
without purpose at that stage I cannot
think of a better way than using the you
know legislation tools to end this chaos
and then move on to the new situation
Hong Kong's new government is described
by President Xi Jinping as being made up
of what he calls Patriots of China
Leonard says he is optimistic that
President XI and Hong Kong's new chief
executive are managing the city's
Affairs well our economy and our
cultural living tie closely with
mainland China in the past 20 years so I
think this is very good that President
Xi Jinping continued to lead the nation
I think a lot of people question about
the continuity of the power understand
special situation especially now the
international conflict and the trade war
changing the leaders very dangerous to
the country as president XI looks set to
lead China for years to come an
encouraging Prospect for some is a
fierce of one for others Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Hong Kong